hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll you
might have noticed that we've talked a
lot in the podcast about life about the
scientific concept of life especially in
the context of possible kinds of life
elsewhere not here right on earth or at
least not naturally occurring right here
on earth we talked to Kate at Amala
about synthetic life about actually
building living organisms in the
laboratory we talked to Sara Amari
Walker about information and what that
has to do with life how living beings
use information but also how information
helps us define what it means to a
living being
to be a living being and we talked to
Kevin hand about actually looking for
life elsewhere here in the solar system
in all of these discussions we've
mentioned the fact that we don't have a
once and for all definition of what life
actually is but we sort of mentioned
that mumbled about it and moved on to
something else so let's take the
opportunity to actually dig in today's
guest is stuart bartlett who's a
researcher here at Caltech at my own
University and he's an expert in what
life actually means what the word life
means he and his collaborator Michael
Wang recently published a paper that
actually goes through all of the
different features of what come into
being a living being and make the point
that some of these features might not
exist in every single thing you want to
call life
so they actually define some new words
and they hypothesize about which of
these features such as learning and
homeostasis would come first which are
more important than which would come
later and the answer is you know we
don't know it's a very it's a wonderful
little organizational tool to remind us
of how much work there is to be done to
really understand what it means to
undergo a transition from simply some
complex chemical reaction to something
we would actually call life and it
harkens back to the various talks that
we've had you know information plays a
huge role here the possibility is a
building life in the laboratory are
mentioned we go pretty deep stuart and i
in this conversation we talk about life
on computers you know surprises in
evolution a whole bunch of good things
that one of those mind stretching
episodes and
possibly one that's going to be really
really relevant to science in the near
future as our ability to look for life
elsewhere both in the solar system and
on other planets on other stars becomes
better and better so this is a good one
to make your brain grow and also prepare
us for the future what else do you look
for in a good podcast episode so with
that let's go
[Music]
let's do it partly welcome to the
mindscape podcast thank you for inviting
me here it's a great honor to be with
you today thanks I wish more people
would recognize what an honor it is but
I'm glad that you that you put it that
way
we are honored to have you here
especially I've talked a few times on
the podcast about life you know the
definition of life and life looking for
life another plane is the origin of life
but it's always been you know in the
service of something else we talked with
Kate Adam ala about synthetic life and
Sarah Walker about the relationship of
information and life and Kevin hand we
talked with about looking for life here
in the solar system but so lurking in
the background here something that to
bring up every single time is what do
you mean by life what is the definition
of this year so I'm glad we're finally
going to answer this once and for all
but maybe maybe I can start by just
asking you know do we need a definition
of life is this something that is just
arguing over words or is it really
crucial to scientific understanding yeah
that's a great question and you can
really argue this either way of course
the most conventional affirmative answer
is that we need a definition of life so
that we can design plan strategize and
aim towards a common objective so much
of modern science is objective driven
when you write proposals and you and you
design missions you have to have a very
very clear goal in mind and and a lot of
what we do is taking incremental steps
towards those goals and astrobiology
even though it is let's say at least 50
years old it's a field which has a broad
scattering of opinions and a complete
lack of consensus on almost anything
there are a lot of opinions that noticed
that out there they're definitely people
with strong opinions about things
exactly one of it's one of these
situations where the less something is
constrained the more sure that people
feel about their opinions on it
and so
so one could say that we should have a
definition of life so that we're at
least to a certain extent agreed on what
we're looking for especially when we
design missions looking for
extraterrestrial life and and also in
the context of the origins of life a
very difficult problematic question is
what would qualify as a successful
demonstration so for example if someone
did an experiment in the lab and they
said I have proven that life began in
this way right we have no in the
astrobiology field we have no
agreed-upon standard of what constitutes
absolute proof of a and abiogenesis
number two and I mean NASA has its
definition which is probably the most
commonly adhere to definition but there
is still entirely what tell us what that
is yes the NASA definition of life is a
self-sustaining chemical system capable
of Darwinian evolution you know
evolution or Darwinian evolution in
particular features heavily in in most
definitions of life and in the early
days of origins of life research and and
still to a strong extent today there's
this almost tacit assumption that
whatever your prebiotic system is once
it shows definitive signs of Darwinian
evolution then you can probably leave
the rest to to be discovered and
constructed by that evolutionary process
so it's it's sort of tacitly hoped that
evolution is the explanation for the
complexity of life and you just have to
get to that starting point and then
evolution will take over for you
I don't share that opinion I don't know
whether I'm unsure as to whether just
Darwinian evolution is sufficient to
explain the diversity of life on earth
so I'm not confident that we can rely on
Darwinian evolution to to explain
the complexity that we see after that
origins starting point okay we so these
are fighting words obviously I can't
just let you get away with saying that
so maybe you can define exactly what you
mean by Darwinian evolution because I
suspect a lot of work is being done by
that phrase and then in what ways do you
think it's insufficient yeah so the
first course that I took on evolution
was taught by Professor Richard Watson
at the University of Southampton and and
I'll never forget he would summarize it
in a very compact way in the following
in the following phrase heritable
variation leading to reproductive
success mm-hmm
so there's basically three components to
Darwinian evolution there's heredity so
the ability for information to be passed
from one generation to the next
there has to be a variation so when you
when organism reproduces the next
generation has to consist of a finite
number of individuals and they cannot
all be identical and we tend to say that
if they're identical then that's
replication if they're if there are if
there's variation and it's reproduction
okay so there's variation among the
offspring and then there are selective
forces which will tend to favor those
members of the new population which are
more fit to the environment more better
suited to the environment and it will
disfavor those which are less suited to
the environment and and of course this
is this is the theory of biology and
Darwinian evolution has been has been
studied in all kinds of different ways
you know beyond just phylogenetics and
studying the modern biosphere in the
field of a life people study the process
of evolution through digital evolution
experiments to very probably define what
a life is yes hey so so a life is a very
interesting discipline a life stands for
artificial life and by artificial life
we mean alternative forms of life in
some sense
so the research in artificial life
consists of things like artificial
intelligence and robotics evolutionary
robotics so people when people design
robots they maybe they can design it and
hand program it and it works but often
when you're trying to get a robot to
solve difficult tasks you have to you
have to basically evolve the software
and and often these robots become quite
unquote intelligent in their own right
and and you you basically evolve their
programming so maybe you have you have
several different sets of programming
for that for your robot and you you see
how well it achieves the desired task
and then you take you rank the
performance take the best ones and then
maybe recombine the features of the best
ones and then reiterate that process
then you basically mimic the
evolutionary process in the programming
of your robot right and eventually the
performance should increase okay so even
in the artificial life context people
are using Darwinian evolution but you
want to say it's not sufficient to do
something tell me you tell me what it's
nice efficient to do researchers in the
field of a life have for a long time
been seeking this this this grand goal
of what they call open-ended evolution
an open-ended evolution means evolution
of a population of individuals which
just keep changing and keep becoming
more complex over time and show no sign
of sort of settling and saturating mm-hm
and when we look at the biosphere on
earth it looks like evolution of Earth
based life is open-ended because there's
there's no sign that evolution ever got
bored and stopped innovating and
generating new levels of complexity so
if we understand at the evolution of
life on Earth
we should be able to as Fineman said
when you understand something you should
be able to reconstruct it and so if we
understand evolution we should be able
to reiterate it in a way that shows this
open-ended generation of novelty
and and so researchers in the field of a
life have built a large range of models
where you have artificial organisms
which reproduce with heredity and
variation and then they impose selective
courses on those populations in the in
many of the examples these are basically
digital organisms that they're just sets
of code and they're actually competing
for CPU time and memory access and and
the idea is that if we if we let these
populations evolve if the process is
similar to evolution of life on Earth
then we should see emergent novel
features so maybe for example they form
groups and the group start competing or
they form new that they they invent new
ways of existing in their digital
environment and and so that's what what
would potentially count as open-ended
evolution but in reality what tends to
happen is that those systems do evolve
to a certain extent so there are changes
in the code and they they they they do
develop certain functionalities but what
tends to happen is you have one set of
those entities which are able to
reproduce themselves quite well but then
you have a set of parasites which come
along with them which emerge in the
system and they will essentially
piggyback on the replica the more stable
replicators and those more stable
replicators then find it difficult to
generate new levels of norrland novelty
because their resources are being
expended not only on their own
replication but on the replication of
just those those small bits of code
which they're a bit like viruses in some
ways and what you find is that the
complexity of the system basically just
saturates out at that point and it is
not able to develop further and there
was a similar experiment by Spiegelman
on small sections of RNA and you can ask
the same question if you have our RNA
molecules which are able to
perhaps replicate themselves in a in a
collective sense again you have a
replication process or a reproduction
process and there is also heredity
because there's information in the
sequence of the RNA molecules and
there's also selection for reproductive
efficiency and again one would hope that
if you let the experiment run you would
see immersion new levels of function or
complexity but it turns out that
actually those RNA molecules evolve
towards simplicity not towards
complexity and actually they just that
they end up evolving towards the minimal
sequence capable of replication and then
they stop there
then he pause for a second to talk about
indeed.com the number one job site in
the world where you have access to the
largest pool of talent and can hire the
right people fast unlike other sites
indeed gives you full control and
payment flexibility over who you hire
you only pay for what you need you can
pause your account at any time and there
are no long term contracts
plus indeed provides powerful tools to
make your search so much easier like
sponsored jobs which are shown to be
three and a half times more likely to
result in a higher with 73% of online
job seekers visiting indeed each month
indeed is going to get you the important
hire you need just like they have for
over three million businesses right now
indeed is offering our listeners a free
$75 credit to boost your job post which
means more quality candidates will see
it fast try and deed out with a free
seventy five dollar credit at indeed.com
slash mindscape that's the best offer
they have available anywhere terms and
conditions apply offer valid through
September thirtieth go right now to
indeed.com slash mindscape this is
fascinating I had actually never heard
of this idea that in the artificial life
context complexity saturates and and
furthermore it's because of these
parasites so I'm not quite sure what the
causality is there why
diseases of these parasites cause the
main artificial virtual life forms to
stop innovating yes I the in general the
answer seems to be something called the
cooperation barrier which is that when a
replicating system is sort of headed
towards let's say a higher level of
organization for example if there is a
set of simple replicators and and we
believe that there is a way for those
simple replicators to cooperate and
perhaps share resources maybe maybe
maybe some of the replicators are more
specialized as some functions than
others and we know that if they
cooperated and shared those functions
then the collective whole would actually
be able to replicate at a more efficient
rate we can ask the question if there is
some kind of collective favorability for
that cooperation what does it take for
that cooperation to emerge if we know
that it's favorable and it turns out
that this there's this cooperation
barrier is is the fundamental issue so
let's imagine that by some fluctuation
these originally selfish individuals
begin cooperating and they discover this
higher level of organization which is
beneficial if one of those individuals
in the cooperating group reverts back to
a more selfish way of living where it
takes its share of the resources but
doesn't contribute a similar level of
resources to the group then in the short
term that individual will be favored
because it can basically steal and
reproduce itself and without having to
wait for the whole collective to
reproduce itself and what you find in
these experiments is that those we
sometimes call them cheaters or selfish
individuals those cheaters
in in that short-term favorable
situation where they can basically steal
resources from the group they will tend
to out-compete the co-operators and take
over the group and then you go back to
the previous level of organization
without the cooperation and so this is
something that's also studied in
evolutionary game theory yeah what and
it seems to it seems to apply today's
digital evolution experiments and
perhaps even to some of these RNA
replication experiments and in general
on the open endedness side people people
have looked at the history of life on
earth and tried to delineate what they
call major transitions
yeah idea is due to air shaft nari and
John Maynard Smith where we see changes
in the organizational structure of life
so the transition from single celled
organisms to multi-celled organisms is
one example and so in that transition
it's it's similarly an issue of why
would those previously individual
selfish organisms decide to give up some
of their own resources and and cooperate
for that for that collective
favorability because often it takes some
time for the for the advantages of being
in a group to be to be reflected in the
selective forces and so this is this is
sort of a generic problem in
evolutionary game theory in artificial
life and there are different theories
out there for how you combat this
cooperation barrier so some people argue
that you know there has to be some kind
of regulation mechanism or a suppression
mechanism to try and to try and suppress
the cheating behavior and I mean we can
also draw analogies with society itself
it with society itself there's also a
short term selection pressure for
cheating and stealing you know in in
theory there are ways that you can cheat
and steal from the group and in the
short term you will be better off
but the group in the long term will be
worse off and and we have to try and
suppress that uncooperative behavior
with with dedicated mechanisms for that
okay so fine so there's this so what
you're saying is that at least in our
artificial experiments Darwin evolution
all by itself where the analog thereof
seems to sort of reach this bottleneck
or blockade or fix point equilibrium
that doesn't look like what life looks
like here on earth so how do you fix it
are you gonna say that God comes in and
stirs things up and makes us more
complex yes well that's the question
that everyone is trying to answer and
and so again people people suggest that
you need some auxiliary mechanism which
is able to which is able to suppress the
cheating behavior or you have to have
selective forces at the group level
which are strong enough and in in
biology there's still a lot of debate
about whether group selection really
exists ever since Richard Dawkins I
guess we tend to focus on the selection
of fairly low level entities like the
genes or the individuals right and so
many biologists are skeptical about the
possibility that there can be true
selective forces acting on the group but
if we if we look at it at that level
let's say we have several several groups
of individuals which are replicating we
could make an argument that out of those
groups the ones which are best able to
suppress the cheating and best able to
cooperate should probably out-compete
the groups which are being dragged down
more significantly by the cheating so it
has been a sort of intuitive level group
selection it feels like groups like sand
could be acting and but is it is it is
it fair to say that that's not Darwinian
evolution I mean isn't that something
that is just part and parcel of
Darwinian evolution yeah it does is a
good question is whether whether it's
you could say that is maybe a higher
manifestation of
Darwinian evolution or you could say
well it's something different and in
fact going back to my lecturer Richard
Watson he has proposed that actually
evolution is more like a large
associative learning system and and that
and that can potentially explain the
formation of these groups in that
basically the the whole system whole
ecosystems for example are essentially
learning about their environments and
learning about one another and they and
they they're learning by observing
correlations in those in the environment
and amongst each other and and gradually
the the populations are are becoming
more knowledgeable and have a greater
understanding of their environment and
and that that is a more a more general
explanation of evolution that it's it's
basically this this giant learning
algorithm there's also another author
called Leslie valiant who's discussed
these ideas in his book probably
approximately correct and of course it's
it's not trivial to figure out it if you
say well a ecosystems or the biosphere
as a whole his giant learning system
it's not clear it's not clear how its
how exactly it's doing the learning I
mean again Richard has argued that it's
it's associative or heavy and learning
correlation learning so which is which
is where the system is observing
correlations in external variables for
example I don't know if it if the sky
becomes dark and cloudy is quite likely
that then it's gonna rain and if you're
an organism that really doesn't like
rain then you probably want to get out
of the way yeah before the rain arrives
and so it's advantageous if you if you
correlate those two things and you can
get out of harm's way before the danger
actually arrives then you will be better
off than if you didn't learn that
association it's for
in some sense yeah yeah but yeah but but
wait I mean I saw I think I actually I
feel bad because we've gotten off of the
question of the definition of life I do
want to go back there but this is just
so fascinating yeah that's okay we
should talk about fascinating things but
I mean nothing you're saying makes me
think that there isn't some purely
reductionistic level at which we talk
about genes being passed on to other
future generations and then some of them
reproduce and some of them don't and I'm
very happy with their also being
interesting emergent higher level
descriptions that give us true causal
handles on what's going on but they're
not you know overriding the
reductionistic level in any way so
that's why I think that you know I'm
perfectly happy saying all this is 100%
compatible with traditional Darwinian
evolution mmm
so yeah that's that's a good point and
it is possible that that all the
causation is bottom up there yeah
heavily that the Darwinian evolution is
the driving force and that these
higher-level phenomena are are just
emerging
downstream effects of the Darwinian
evolution at the bottom one of the
primary counter examples is the one of
the most interesting major transitions
which again goes back to group selection
and that's the emergent of social
behavior in insects so if we look at the
ants for example and if we look at think
if we just go and look at a given ant
colony when we pluck out an individual
at random we will find that maybe like a
worker ant
for example huh now if we look at that
worker ant we could look at it cells and
sequences genes and and we could ask
okay how fit is this individual well
it's pretty fit because those ants are
extremely sophisticated they they have a
complex social structure and they you
know they they they farm other organisms
very very sophisticated behavior so that
ant is clearly doing well and if we look
at its behavior we would observe that
it's it's going to work its entire life
tirelessly for the for the benefit of
the colony but then if
we asked well it's it seems like it's
part of a very resilient community and
it's dedicated to its it's life of
labour but is it actually going to
reproduce and the answer is no the vast
majority of the ants in the colony are
not going to pass their genes on to the
next generation and so the question is
under under the Darwinian paradigm we
would say that while every individual is
going to be is going to be filtered out
by natural selection and the most fit
ones are going to pass on their genes to
the next generation but that individual
worker ant which is apparently doing
really well it's not going to pass its
genes on to the next generation and and
it's you know it's cooperating in this
collective but it's not its genes are
not getting anything out of that
cooperation because its genes are not
gonna be passed on to the next
generation
so that's kind of one of the one of the
conundrums that is put to the those who
think that Darwinian evolution alone can
it can explain everything is how do we
explain the emergence of social behavior
in insects okay I think that um this
could be a whole podcast all by itself a
great one but I just want to you know
very quickly you know put a cap on it by
saying what you're suggesting is that
some kind of downward causation that is
not part of the traditional Darwinian
recipe is helpful to understand the
evolution of life here on earth not that
it's like creationism or something like
that just making sure because there are
people who will get worried about that
okay good so in the definition then the
reason why we got on to this is because
NASA puts Darwinian evolution right
there in the evolute in the definition
of life and you don't think that's a
good idea well my concern that I share
with some of my collaborators in
particular Mike one where we just sort
of published these ideas recently so
what what we're concerned about is
whether the definition might be too
eccentric essentially because we only
have one example of life to study that
makes it very very difficult to
generalize
and and the question is when we look for
life elsewhere what features do we
expect extraterrestrial life to share
with life on earth and what features
might we expect to be different and of
course NASA expects that life elsewhere
will be chemically based and it will be
evolving and again me and Mike are great
fans of Star Trek and in Star Trek you
you you see all kinds of different forms
of life and yeah some of which are not
chemically based and and so when you try
to open your mind and take inspiration
from things like Star Trek you you
wonder whether chemical life and
evolution by natural selection is the
only way of doing it and that what we
fear is that what if there's life out
there which which does not evolve by
Darwinian evolution and maybe or maybe
it's not chemically based but it's there
what if what if we miss it because our
definition is wrong or our definition is
off the mark and so I think it's always
been useful to me to sort of keep in
mind examples of systems that we know of
here on earth that have some features of
life but don't count as life and then
the idea of a definition of life would
be to distinguish something like you
know a hurricane is not alive but an
anteater is do you have your favorite
examples of sort of warning counter
examples to keep in mind yes I mean I'm
I'm a big fan of these so-called
disappear structures and have worked
with a few of them during my career so
my favorites are convection cells but
very simple I mean a hurricane is a very
very elaborate complex convection cell
yeah a convection cell being an ordered
structure that arises in a
differentially heated fluid so if you
heat a fluid from the bottom and cool it
from the top instead of the heat moving
magis homogeneously through the fluid it
forms these these beautiful overturning
roles and and you can do the experiment
in a saucepan maybe with some noodles or
something
noodles will kind of align themselves
with the flow and you see this this
lovely hexagonal pattern of convection
cells and my other favorite example is
pattern forming chemical systems and
arguably the first patent for me
chemical system was the Palouse of
Hobart insky reaction and famously they
couldn't they can get their experiments
published for a long time because it
formed these interesting patterns but no
one believed them that it was actually
real because it seemed to violate the
second law of thermodynamics
like you say a little bit more about
what this reaction is this is something
in a petri dish or what yes so it's a
you basically makes I think it's malonic
acid it's it's not actually that simple
you do have to mix several different
things together and normally when you
when you mix reactants together you
would expect the reaction to proceed in
a particular direction and eventually
the system would come to a Calibri
Ehrman the reaction would be done in the
bz reaction in fact you see oscillations
and you see waves in the in the in the
concentrations of different chemical
species so if you put some dyes in the
system then these these patterns are
very nicely sort of illustrated and it
so it involves things like potassium
bromate cerium sulfate malonic acid
sulfuric acid so you have to sort of mix
these things in the right way and then
if you if you wait for a little while
you start to see oscillations and spiral
waves in the concentrations of different
chemical species and the point is that
there they look organized and there you
know in some sense processing energy
from their environment but no one is
gonna say that they're alive exactly so
so there are lots of variations you can
do of these kind of reactions so there
are model systems such as for example
the cell called reaction which is just
which is an artificial chemical system
but it's it's it kind of encompasses
these effects and that reaction you just
react one more
or a species with two molecules of bee
species then you get three molecules of
the species B and it turns out that just
just that reaction if you tune the
diffusion coefficients of these chemical
species and you and you let that system
run under different sets of parameters
you can get very elaborate patterns
including these spot patterns which will
grow and then divide and it looks
exactly like replicating bacteria in a
petri dish hmm so that system which I
studied during my PhD is is very
interesting because again there's this
superficial similarity to simple life
because those chemical structures will
grow and divide and replicate and so as
you as you said previously we can ask
you know what if it looks like life what
is it what has it got that life has and
what does it not have that life has and
in this case it definitely has
replication because you can see that
replication happening before your own
eyes of course it doesn't evolve and if
we try and think about heredity while
the each time there's the replication of
those spot patterns the offspring
basically carry the chemical species of
the parents and that's about it so the
heredity is very limited however
something that I found during my PhD is
that actually if you run if you simulate
systems with several populations of
these things you can observe cooperative
behavior between the different
populations and in particular something
that I experimented with is if if one
set of these spot patterns produces heat
and the other population absorbs heat
they can actually regulate their
temperature and if you try and sort of
kill them by heating up the system or
cooling down the system they will
respond by changing their relative
populations and hence they will
basically protect themselves from
thermal damage and again those systems
are it's just chemical reactions very
simple chemical reaction and yet they
they so self-replication they they show
homeostasis they can expand into regions
of
their space which were previously
inhospitable and and a friend of mine
Martin Hank zyk has also done similar
experiments with oil droplets and oil
droplets will show chemotaxis so they
will they will basically follow a
gradient of chemical species which
powers them and you can use that effect
to get them to solve mazes for example I
really don't know like these are clearly
just little blobs of chemicals they're
not no one's going to mistake them from
being alive but they can salt they can
learn enough to solve the mains exactly
exactly and they can and if you if you
sort of if you lay out a path of their
food in front of them they will follow
it in the same way that bacteria do
shopping for life insurance can be scary
and intimidating how much coverage do
you need which company is the best one
for you how much should it even cost and
at a time when it's more important than
ever to have life insurance the pandemic
is making it a little bit more
complicated to shop for it that's where
policy genius can help as a life
insurance marketplace backed by a team
of experts policy genius is keeping
track of all the changes in the market
so you don't have to they'll find you
the right amount of coverage at the best
possible price without the headache
policy genius compares quotes from the
top life insurance companies all in one
place it'll just take you a few minutes
to compare quotes from the top insurers
to find your best price you could just
save fifteen hundred dollars or more a
year by using policy genius to compare
life insurance policies so if you need
life insurance but you're not sure where
to start
head to policy genius com policy genius
will find you the best rate and handle
the process completely they'll get you
and your family protected and hopefully
give you one less thing to worry about
try it today okay so this is the
challenge that we're faced with right
that there are all these things that are
kind of have some properties in common
with life but are not and you and
Michael Wong had faced this challenge by
inventing a whole new word and why don't
you tell us what the new word is and
what are the ingredients that go into
defining what it is yes they we wanted
to try and clarify this question of what
is life
by introducing a new terminology to
encompass so we leave life with an eye
to refer to life that we're familiar
with ie D nucleic acid-based information
transfer and protein based metabolisms
and the the lipid membrane compartments
that we're familiar with so so we
ascribe that to life with an i l they
know
in other words L IFE L IFE and then we
introduced a new term L Y Fe which at
the moment we pronounce lloyd boy that I
thought was Browns the same okay we
introduced life as a larger set of
entities which encompass what we have
introduced as a more general definition
of life and so that larger set of
entities satisfies four criteria which
we've introduced as as a sort of larger
overarching definition of life and life
is a subset of that larger set which
applies to life on Earth after after it
had evolved from simpler systems and so
so the four criteria and to be satisfied
for a system to be life is dissipation
which just means that the system cannot
be in thermodynamic equilibrium it can't
be a an isolated closed system because
we observed that life always uses
sources of free energy and it always
dissipates free energy so it takes
concentrated energy uses it for its own
functions and then expels less useful
less useful energy and ultimately at the
scale of the planet we have concentrated
UV light coming in and less concentrated
infrared light going out and there's
that right now a loss of free energy
involved the second characteristic is
auto catalysis which is another way of
saying exponential growth
so we would always expect life to
exhibit exponential growth when it has
access to abundant resources so when you
when you look at a bacteria in a petri
dish and when it has abundant resources
it will grow exponentially the
population will increase exponentially
as it replicates and we introduce this
characteristic because we don't we
expect nonlinear behavior in living
systems because whether it's replication
or the enhanced exploitation of new
niches the activity of of life under
abundant conditions always leads to an
enhancement of that activity and there's
so we expect there's always going to be
the potential for that positive feedback
and then third characteristic is
homeostasis which is quite common to
definitions of light because you
observed that life is very good at
regulating certain important variables
yeah maybe give us a definition of what
homeostasis means we've actually talked
about it a lot we had a podcast with
Antonio Damasio who's a big fan of the
concept but in the in this context what
do we mean yes so in this context we
basically mean negative feedback
mechanisms that are able to that are
able to rein in key physical or chemical
variables such that the entity is stable
I mean for us humans the the
characteristic example is often blood
glucose level if blood glucose level is
too high or too low then we suffer
fairly catastrophic effects temperature
is another one you know we can we can
tolerate certain changes of temperature
but we have to do a certain amount of
self regulation otherwise we suffer a
lot of negative metabolic impacts and
and you can also look at it at
collective levels I mean again the Gaia
hypothesis would be another it would be
a whole nother podcast and I'm not I'm
not saying I think the stronger
hypothesis is true but the sorry Talton
tell us what the stronger hypothesis is
the stronger our hypothesis is that the
whole of planet Earth can be considered
an organism in itself which by nature of
being an organism regulates itself such
that it is more resilient and and and
stays within environment within a good
range supportive range of environmental
parameters so for example it doesn't the
earth doesn't allow itself to lose its
atmosphere in the way that Mars did and
so it it doesn't allow itself to
experience like a runaway greenhouse on
the other hand and oil off the oceans it
doesn't allow itself to plunge into a
permanent snowball earth it's kind of
decrease in area but instead it it it
activates mechanisms to keep itself in a
in a comfortable in a comfortable state
right okay
that's homeostasis that we regulate
ourselves to be comfy exactly and of
course you need homeostasis to keep the
autocatalytic property in check again
going back to this sort of co-operators
versus cheaters we are at multicellular
organisms and so we have to regulate the
replication rate of our own cells and
ourselves our make basically signing a
contract with one another in that sense
and if we have a stray cell which breaks
that contract and replicates faster than
all the others then you end up with with
cancer and so it's it's a key it's a key
product so the so I mean maybe I didn't
quite understand Auto catalysis
therefore well enough I mean the auto
that I should associate the auto
catalytic property with the idea of
growth exponential growth but as I is
that in the number of organisms or is it
in the number of cells per organism
individual organisms or is even thinking
of organisms to Tuba night it at this
level of generality yeah it's a good
question so in general for a life on
Earth we tend to think of it as the cell
count but in principle for exotic life
elsewhere
may-maybe maybe that life doesn't it's
not comprised of cells in the same way
and you know perhaps it would apply to a
different variable for example a free
energy consumption and we can if we were
to if we look at graphs of the human
species of changes in the human species
in the last several hundred years the
population of humans has increased
exponentially and also that you know the
consumption of mineral resources the
consumption of free energy these things
have also followed exponential like
curves and so it may not necessarily
apply to individual organism count but
it should it should be possible to find
some measure of that living system which
when under ideal conditions grows
exponentially I guess I mean maybe this
I know you only done with three of your
four pillars here but maybe to help us
focus what these are supposed to apply
to I mean maybe this race is an
interesting question of do we think of
life on an organism by organism basis or
do we think of it as the entire
biosphere all at once you know I had
David Baltimore on very recently talking
about viruses and a common question
about viruses is are they alive and
Baltimore's answer was well of course
they're alive because they're part of
life
they can't survive on their own they
don't fulfill all these criteria by
themselves but they're part of this
larger process and is it I mean is that
a paradigm shift we should try to make
from thinking about the process of life
as a whole rather than whether this or
not individual organism is alive yes
exactly this is a great point and I do
agree with the this quote from Baltimore
in that I I do think it's wrong to just
say that viruses are not alive because
as time goes by we see more and more
evidence that they are even though they
have these terrible destructive effects
there are they are still an integral
part of the biosphere there they
massively outnumber other organisms and
so they are contributing somehow and we
probably don't understand the extent of
their country
yet and so we definitely apply our
definition to the system level maybe
maybe even the the planetary level or
the ecosystem level right yeah if you
pluck out if you just pluck out
individual entities from the system it's
it's quite likely that those individual
objects will not satisfy the criteria
but the system as a whole will and along
with several other authors in
astrobiology I would definitely I would
lean towards life being a planetary
phenomenon rather than a rather than
something that happens at the individual
level yeah okay good
and so let's contextualise your pillars
in terms of that you mentioned
dissipation so you know life as a whole
the system level clearly we're using up
the free energy we get from the Sun and
dissipating it auto catalysis at least
in some sense party this is this is yeah
this is where I'm struggling so numbers
two and number three where auto
catalysis which is growth and
homeostasis which is stasis and so if we
I mean is is I would guess that auto
catalysis applies to the system and
homeostasis applies to the individuals
or at least little sub environments
thereof yes again another question
another good question because there are
different timescales at work here and
different and and fluctuations as well
as sort of equilibrium so as you point
out if if something is perfectly
homeostatic then it's not going to
expand and and how and how does it
innovate right now we're just suggesting
that those mechanisms be represented in
the system and be identifiable in the
system right okay and also the the
interaction between the fourth pillar
which is probably the trickiest one of
learning is another there's another
interesting area because because yeah
auto catalysis implies significant
change whereas homeostasis implies
return-to-work will appear
but of course learning implies changed
as well and and and they the the
feedbacks between these pillars there's
something that we will we will elaborate
on in future work so you know under what
circumstances can Auto catalysis break
homeostasis in such a way that the
system it maybe expands and innovates
and there might be other circumstances
where the system is trying to be also
catalytic and expand but its homeostatic
mechanisms are bringing it back so yeah
this is this is a big question that
we're that we're going to explore
further in future I would say but maybe
okay so your fourth pillar is learning
and I think maybe it would be helpful to
be more specific about how that arises I
mean do do fungi learn do trees learn do
bacteria learn definitely good so
explain what that means cuz they don't
go to school they don't get grades yeah
so this is again quite an open aspect
and and probably the most interesting
and also them they're probably the most
important though because we talked about
nonliving systems which exhibit some of
these characteristics and crucially
those nonliving systems did not exhibit
any learning capability there are
nonliving systems capable of learning I
mean
neural networks is the classic example
of course and there are even there even
just simple physical systems like shared
fluids which can show hysteresis and
memory in fact I'm right now I'm working
on convection systems that are capable
of computation so so well I think I
think I mean maybe I don't even too much
of a hard time here but I want a
definition of what learning means like
if I walk down the beach I leave
footprints on it and as the beach
learned about the shape of my foot yeah
good question so learning it is somewhat
of an umbrella term that encompasses
several different aspects and memory is
one of those a space oh yeah when you
walk down the beach and you leave a
footprint in it has the beach learned
about you
learned about your presence hmm so yeah
the beach has exhibited a memory and
it's interacted with you somehow the
question is will that memory that if the
information in that imprint that you
left will it be processed will it be
used will it feedback on anything else
so if the beach for example let's say
your footprint was left in the beach and
then and then the sand sort of
rearranged itself into a different
structure maybe it did like made a copy
of the inverse of your foot and then
copied that a hundred times into a tall
pillar and and that had an effect on the
way that the waves washed the washed the
sand along the seashore and maybe made
the beach more resilient to the erosive
effects of the waves well then we would
say crikey that beach interacted with
Shawn's foot and it learned something
it's somehow processed that information
and use the information to protect
itself from destruction if it did that
then we would say well that that seems
like a learning behavior it encoded
information processed the information
and it used the information and likewise
there's often analogies made between
life and fire because fire yeah kind of
has a metabolic process because it's
converting free energy in the fuel to
lower free energy forms and it it
replicates itself you know it grows and
show you supported catalysis and you
know does it does it exhibit homeostasis
well you know certain things it doesn't
it doesn't explode and completely
encompass everything in it in a huge
area surrounding it instantly so it's
it's autocut ah what's a catalytic to a
certain level but it's not homeostatic
in the general case because once it
burns itself out it dies and it also
doesn't learn we can imagine a different
form of fire which which somehow
interacts with the fuel environment
around it and adjusts its burning rate
adaptively such that it never burns out
of course in fact fire does
do that so fire is not capable of
learning and hence we don't consider it
to be alive and so in general we define
learning as three abilities the ability
to interact with the environment and
record information the ability to
process that information to change its
form somehow and then after processing
that the use of that information such
that the organism it has somehow
increased its utility its benefit as a
result of interacting with that
information because of course there are
lots of ways that you could record and
process information but not actually
make good use of it and and so and
natural selection is kind of like a
feedback effect of that nature in the
sense that it chooses it chooses
organisms which are making functional
use of information that they receive
okay so it the learning is not just
taking in information recording it but
using it processing it somehow and so
just to be SuperDuper clear here in what
sense does a tree do that right so trees
are a great example and I wish I wish
they knew more about trees because I
know that they communicate with one
another they are very sensitive to the
environment they process information and
and they make use of that information so
there have been some experiments I think
they were done in British Columbia where
they actually discovered that the the
trees were communicating with each other
via chemical signals and sharing
resources based on which resources were
abundant for one individual and which
were scarce for another individual but
one of the one of the great examples of
long-term learning by trees is right
here in California and it's the the
Bristlecone pine which is I believe the
oldest those that there's a Bristlecone
pine in the White Mountains of
California which is the oldest known
organ
in the world believe is something of the
order of four to five thousand years old
by I think five thousand years old and
and one of the interesting adaptations
of the Bristlecone pine is that it's
it's cones with containing the seeds are
activated by fire so you tend to we tend
to think of forest fires as being
destructive I mean they cause they cause
huge amount of damage to our human
infrastructure and and cause loss of
life so they can be terrible and so we
associate fire with destruction and
damage and what's interesting with the
Bristlecone Pines I mean they're fire
resistant to a certain extent that's not
unique to them there are other trees
which are fire resistant but the fact
that their cones activate and release
the seeds because of fire so the cones
are basically activated by the fire the
reason they the the selective advantage
of that is that a lot of their
competitors are not fire resistant so
once the fire has blown over it's quite
likely that there will be an abundance
of certain resources because other
plants have been destroyed and so this
is a great time for the Bristlecone pine
to lay down its seeds and try and grow
and so and so exactly how the
Bristlecone pine learned that that
characteristic is is the tricky question
of course the first order answer is well
it was again evolution by natural
selection there were there were some
mutations which allowed which produced
the cones that were activated by the
fire and over time that was selected for
so there's the Darwinian answer which is
that it's favorable of course it takes
them it would take a very long time for
that selection pressure to act because
you have to have you would have to have
a large number of fires to for the
Bristlecone to out-compete its
competitors so whether it's by evolution
through natural selection or some other
more sophisticated learning system like
an Associated associative
learning mechanism like a Lamarckian sir
in within lifetime in these trees live a
long time somehow or other this tree has
learned that fire can be used to its
advantage even though for the majority
of organisms fire is is destructive so I
think yeah I mean I think that does
clarify in my mind what's going on so in
in perfect accord with what we said
before about the system's level view
rather than the organism level view
you're counting learning as a species
figuring out some kind of strategy for
surviving and flourishing even not
necessarily just an individual organism
yes yes and and whole ecosystems because
again in the competition for example for
the oldest organism those I believe
there's another collection of trees
perhaps also in California or Nevada
which is older than 5,000 but it's not
it's not any one particular tree which
which has that which has that record
ages it's the germline and the sort of
community of trees which however have
that age and of course there are also
immortal organisms like the Hydra which
don't have don't have any program cell
death so they could be you know in the
deep ocean there might be organisms that
have been around for for tens of
thousands of years maybe I thought that
the Hydra was a mythical beast with
multiple heads that also yeah so it's
it's it's the character in Greek
mythology but it was also a genus there
are small freshwater organism okay yeah
I don't know about hydras in the real
world so that's a new one to me yeah
there's some in there immortal
there's been some studies basically that
there are hydro which the technical term
is that they don't senesce so most
organisms undergo programmed senescence
which means programmed cell death so at
a certain point in an organism's
lifespan the the cells start to degrade
you know we just call it aging and
gradually gradually this degradation
increases and eventually we die and
basically so I think the first article
was in 1998 by Daniel
Martinez and it was where it was claimed
that Hydra are are immortal and but I
mean it's it's a concave it's a
controversial piece of work say hi okay
I don't know whether it's been proven
outright but okay but - so just - I
think that we can get this in everyone's
brains here so you're saying that there
are these four aspects that together
would be would would qualify you as
being life and maybe even life but I
presumably life is a subset of yeah so
life is a subset of life and
specifically it's it's that subset which
which uses the way that we focus there
are different ways that you could
identify the characteristics the ones
that which we focused on are the sort of
core functions which are the way that
the organism replicates and carries
information which from life is using
nucleic acid and and it's it's a nucleic
acid sequence a polymer which has like a
sugar backbone and phosphate groups and
a base sequence but of course we could
imagine another form of life which
doesn't use nucleic acids but maybe it
has a sequence polymer with where
information is encoded in a particular
in a sequence of one of the side
molecules in this chain and it has a
backbone in the same way that nucleic
acid polymers have a backbone but the
backbone might be different and the
bases might be different so that would
not be life that would be lloyd and the
mode of metabolism we we also make a
distinction there so for it to be life
we expect it to be a metabolism based on
amino acid enzymes and chemiosmosis so
Nick Lane has has written a lot about
the chemiosmotic property of Earth
and and chemiosmosis refers to the
pumping of ions across a membrane and
and the reverse process of allowing
those ions back through a membrane and
converting that energy into a different
form so for example a lot of organisms
will will use a source of energy maybe
light energy or chemical energy to pump
protons for example across the membrane
and and that is a costly exercise and
then later on those protons will be
allowed to come back through the
membrane and they will go through a
molecular machine which sort of turns as
they do it and as it turns it will take
ADP and phosphate molecules and form ATP
which is the energy currency of life so
so life on earth use it we we identify
it as using a metabolism based on
chemiosmosis and the the most important
metabolic cycle is that our TCA cycle
say okay that's that's a key key aspect
of of life's metabolism and and then if
we look at the compartments of life on
earth we see that it's it's a complex of
lipid molecules and proteins and so
again if if we were to find let's say we
found extraterrestrial life which was
using nucleic acids for information
storage and replication and it was using
the our TCA cycle as its metabolism and
chemiosmosis but it was not using lipids
or proteins for its membrane it was
using something completely different
that would not be life that would be
Lloyd that would be Lloyd would still
you'd be pretty excited you'd be excited
yeah yeah yeah you would you would you
jump out of your chair when younger
sequencing yeah I mean oh there the
other thing you talk about in your paper
is there are ways that you can have
subsets of all the four pillars here are
the four pillars of dissipation Auto
catalysis homeostasis and learning and
you mentioned that you know you could
have two or three at a time and it
wouldn't count as life or life but it
would still be you know it may be a step
along the way
yeah exactly
so this goes back to the disparate of
structures that we were talking about
before and one of our inspirations for
this paper was to try and was to try and
distinguish these different things what
do they have which we ascribed to life
and what what are they missing and so we
can take all of the powerful pillars and
look at the different subsets of course
there are eight different subsets which
have less than all four of the pillars
so we talked a little bit about
convection cells and hurricanes so of
course those are systems being driven by
large energy gradients so they're
definitely dissipating energy but we
would say that they're not capable of
learning yeah we could we could ask are
they auto catalytic well you know that
there are some situations where
structures in fluid flows will sort of
replicate so you know vortices in
turbulent flows sometimes it looks like
they're replicating look at like a
common vortex street
so yeah potentially under some
circumstances fluid flows maybe they can
be autocatalytic homeostasis well you
know Jupiter's red spot has been around
for a long time yeah so but of course
these systems are not capable of
learning because there's no identifiable
structure which is encoding information
I mean they are every dynamical system
interacts with its environment and
processes information in some way but if
if that information is passing in being
processed and just washing out and
having no other effects they're not
learning that then there's no real
learning right it's not feeding back on
the existence so there's always this
tight coupling in these discussions
between looking for life elsewhere in
the universe and I think that this is a
very nice framework for thinking about
what you might find along the way and
how it could be different but and the
other question of how life actually
arose here on earth do you think that
this framework of understanding the four
pillars of life in their separate ways
helps you in either one of those either
you know help
understand the origin of life here on
earth or strategies for looking for it
elsewhere or what we might expect to
find elsewhere yes if we hope that it
can it can maybe serve as he neither as
a guide or perhaps as inspiration for
ways that that life could arise because
again when when we conduct experiments
where we're trying to understand the
origins of life as I mentioned before we
don't have any agreed-upon standard for
what would count as a successful
demonstration what would count as a
successful experiment and so potentially
these four pillars if they were when we
refined them over time formalize them a
little bit maybe they could they could
serve as a as a criteria for what what
is successful and and what is a failure
and basically in the past a lot of
experiments focused on focused again on
trying to demonstrate the emergence of a
particular function which which was seen
to be essential for life and then
assuming that the other functions of
life would then follow so an example
would be genetic the replication of
genetic information in the RNA world
theory so for the people working in the
RNA world for them the replication of
information in a genetic polymer is so
essential to life that it has to be
functioning before any other aspects of
life can come along and in general it
comes back to be the the assumed
importance of evolution by natural
selection the opponents of the RNA world
would say well there's no physical
reason for four strings of RNA to just
appear in a system it's a very difficult
molecule to synthesize I hadn't yeah and
why why would a physical system want to
produce strings of RNA so the opposite
so you'd say a counterpoint to that is
that
there is no way that a system would ever
want to produce genetic molecules so
instead why don't we focus on a process
which is physically favored and see
whether the functions of life can emerge
out of that so others focus on the
metabolic aspect where you have a
gradient of free energy so the
dissipation pillar is satisfied so the
system wants to dissipate free energy it
wants to it wants to try and équilibre
and in the process of equilibrate
perhaps it can carry out some lifelike
functions
maybe synthesize amino acids for example
and then so for those authors once that
process is running maybe the genetic
molecules might be produced as a side
effect of the metabolism and then the
use of those genetic molecules to encode
sequence information would be
accidentally discovered later on and so
so because we're as humans when we
engineer things we tend to first
manufacture the components and then put
the components together to make the
whole if you think about like a
production line in manufacturing quiet
and so so some of the approaches in the
origins of life have pursued ways to
produce the components of life for some
people the most important component is
amino acids leading to proteins and for
others it's nucleotides which as I
mentioned they're notoriously difficult
to synthesize but there has been
progress made and and so I often wonder
if those experiments succeed and we have
a chemical scheme which synthesizes
those components we will then stumble
across the problem of what is the
physical driving force for those
components to come together and
cooperate in a way that's recognizably
alive and so and so hence that was part
of our motivation for the four pillars
because the four pillars are processes
they're not objects or components well
they could be manifested in different
chemical waves exactly
and so and I mean I'm actually I go back
and forth in my own mind I go back and
forth about whether whether it's more
likely that the four pillars emerged
sequentially or whether they all were
there from the very beginning because I
I mean to be honest I think I find it
unlikely that the function the functions
the various functions of life emerged
sequentially that I mean nature always
surprises us especially the living world
and given given the dramatic extent to
which the living world surprises us I
find it almost impossible to imagine
that the most mysterious aspect of life
would be would be that predictable that
first came this and then came this and
then and then this much and then somehow
it magically came together and then we
got like so instead I think it's more
likely that the origins of life was this
very messy messy chaotic process and
maybe life began several times and you
know it went extinct again almost as
much as it originated and then maybe
there was a handful of other survivors
and probably those survivors would have
interacted and perhaps shared material
shared genetic information undergone all
kinds of exchanges and then what emerged
was a kind of amalgam of different
things that had been discovered at the
beginning so even even the idea of life
coming from a single Universal ancestor
I I'm not sure I I'm not sure that we
can definitively say that that was the
case we there are very strong limits on
how far we can reach back in the history
of life based purely on phylogenetic so
so I I think it's it's very much an open
question
I could come up with scenarios where you
first have dissipation so you have a
system that was that's driven out of
equilibrium that's not that's easy for
the earlier because it was a very
turbulent and then I can imagine maybe a
chemical chemical network that was also
catalytic and started
and exponentially grew in the rate at
which it consumed external resources and
then some negative feedbacks could have
could have set in to regulate itself
against external perturbations or rather
if there were several versions of this
metabolic system those which stumbled
upon homeostatic mechanisms would have
out completed the non homeostatic ones
when then perhaps at some stage either
by by means of genetic molecules or even
or even non genetic molecules there was
perhaps some learning process
alternatively you could come up with
scenarios where all four pillars were
there from the very beginning so it's
it's still an open question I think and
and I wouldn't rule out the possibility
that all four characteristics were there
from the beginning I mean we you've
mentioned
so there's the four pillars which which
are sort of I don't know what to call
them aspects of life the dissipation on
auto catalysis homeostasis and learning
but then the more traditional discussion
of these issues that I've heard and then
you've also alluded to is the functions
of different different things that go
into making life the metabolism the
reproduction the compartmentalization
right the little membranes that surround
us and there's a debate going on between
you know which of these comes first it
is it too much to say or is it is it
what you're aiming at to say that
shifting focus from the functions to the
pillars helps us be a little bit more
free in our imagination about how the
different functions might have arisen
and the role and the order in which they
present I mean maybe it's not the
question we should be asking is not
which came first but you know how the
different pillars sort of came to be and
hooked up to get together exactly I
think I think that would be a great step
forward is if our thinking because those
discussions consume a huge amount of
time and energy which came first well I
think this thing came first no I think
this thing came first and and of course
it's possible
mother nature is just laughing at us
saying well you're all wrong because
because it was because it was neither
neither came first there was a bit of
this and a bit of that and interactions
among everything and so yeah I do think
that the ex first discussions I fear
they may be somewhat artificial and they
might be consuming our resources without
without actually teaching us anything
and in general to me the biggest enigma
in the origin of life is the emergence
of the information processing mechanisms
and for some it's some of the most
exciting research going on in origins of
life right now is reconstructing the
history of the ribosomes so the ribosome
is an organelle common to all life
except viruses of course so the ribosome
is a RNA protein complex which
translates genetic information into
protein sequences so the information in
DNA is translated to messenger RNA which
has been translated to transfer RNA the
transfer RNAs are charged with amino
acids and and basically the RNA sequence
is passed through the ribosome and the a
subunit of the ribosome will take the T
RNAs and combine the amino acids into a
growing peptide chain which has the
sequence that was encoded in the RNA
encoded in the DNA
so the ribosome is kind of the Nexus is
that it's the place where where this
chemical information is transformed into
peptide sequence and right the origin of
the genetic code is is it a zoo is a
deep enigma in itself and the question
is why why would a physical system
invent a coding mechanism we can always
look at it after the fact and say well
you have to have the coding system to
translate genetic information to protein
sequence information and
a protein that's assembled without the
right sequence for the most part is not
functional it doesn't do anything useful
that sequence is essential and and so
it's it's not well understood the
connection between well-known physical
forces like for example the second law
of thermodynamics or the principle of
least action how does that link to the
emergence of this highly organized
fistic ated coding system and so so some
researchers in the field have been
looking at the structure of the ribosome
and trying and looking at where
different sub parts of it were added on
in the past and basically retro dick
ting what it looked like at the very
beginning and and they have been able to
sort of reconstruct this very very
primitive early simple ride the same and
so sorry in other words given the
current ribosome was like the minimal
sub part of it it would be functional
exactly so it turns out that the rock as
the ribosome evolved it kind of evolved
by accretion by basically adding extra
sections of RNA like little little loops
example and it turns out that it is
possible to identify these
characteristic points where one of these
loops are one of these RNA sections was
basically tacked on to an existing to an
existing version of the drivers name and
so what what these researchers were able
to do is identify those points where a
new part was added on and say right well
let's let's take that part off when we
take that part of we revert the ribosome
to a slightly earlier point in its
history and it turns out that you can
keep doing that until you've actually
stripped away almost all of the
additions and at that point you get back
to a very very minimal primitive
ribosome which still has the ability to
translate genetic information to protein
sequence information but it doesn't have
all these
more recent additions that have come
along in the in the intervening years
and so it's possible that in in the near
future we will have good information
about the first ribosome and maybe we
can we can sort of reconstruct the the
most primitive possible cell and then we
can ask and then we still have a gap
that we need to understand regarding the
origins of life but the gap it would
have been made a little bit smaller at
that point and so we come back to this
fundamental which question which to me
is a question of thermodynamics and
physics and information theory which is
given the tendency of the second law of
thermodynamics which is for systems to
try and come to Accra Librium for
gradients to dissipate for things to
spread out given that tendency and given
let's say the presence of certain
chemical or physical structures how how
would that tendency be linked to the
emergence of an information processing
system and in fact it doesn't need to be
as complicated as a genetic code or a
write the same because there are also
individual molecules which are capable
of processing information it's been well
known for a long time that protein
molecules can process information and
switch their behavior depending on their
surrounding yeah and there's there's
another class of molecules called
information engines which are molecules
that basically they can make a
measurement of their immediate vicinity
and then change their behavior based on
the measurement that they've made and
then and that behavior can actually be
used to make an energy conversion and so
it's it's quite similar to Maxwell's
demon which makes a measurement and is
able to create free energy
there was none before they can't do it
for free there's a free energy cost
involved in erasing its memory and
likewise information engines in general
will consume a source of energy make a
measurement and create a different
source of energy and so one example is
molecular Walker molecules in modern
life
so those walking molecules will actually
will actually wait for a kick from their
external environment and when a useful
kick when they get pushed forward in the
direction that they want to walk they
will actually consume another source of
energy ATP and lock themselves in the
forward position and and so that is how
they actually walk forward they're not
that their motion is not powered by the
ATP their motion is powered by random
fluctuations in the background but
they're there the sequence of steps that
they go through is selective in the
sense that if the kick is good they will
move forward and lock that position in
by burning the ATP and if the kick is
bad they will do nothing so so this is
another is a it's a fundamental aspect
of the origins problem which is why why
would a physical system given a gradient
plus perhaps some molecules or physical
systems capable of processing
information why would it become
favourable for free energy dissipation
to be linked to the creation of another
gradient or the processing of
information well I think that's a it's a
good place to end as a little bit of
food for thought for people because you
know I completely agree I've I've
thought about this myself you know how
we all know that information is
processed in our own brains and there's
a sense in which all of life processes
information in some sense but getting
that sense exactly right is going to be
important to figuring out how it started
right how the origin the different
there's probably
in one way in which life processes
information it makes use of it and so
the the project of specifying what that
means and and how it came to be is gonna
I think lead to a lot of breakthroughs
in the future
I agree yeah all right well Stuart
partly thanks so much for be on the
podcast you doing this a lot to think
about well thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]